[Music]
oh no so you say Neanderthals and humans
never met well let's get that right
let's get it the way it should be
I'm saying that there's no objective
evidence that humans and Neanderthals
ever met you know let's do a little bit
of history ever since they found the
first and earth oven mid 19th century
there's been all kinds of theories
thrown around of how the Neanderthals
disappeared
and I'd say 90 to 99 percent of them
have to do with humans we either kill
them off we competed them we were better
at hunting or whatever we had more
children and they did and we the latest
one is that we intermarried with them
that we called it mixture and that means
that you know we made it with them and
we humans are the offspring we are the
Neanderthals the chemicals never
disappeared they became us okay that's
theory today the the reigning theory
okay and so the issue here is that
because ninety to ninety nine percent of
the theories always involve man they had
to invent or what developed from there
was a competition for the last man who
thought they had to make sure that
Neanderthal lived to a greater age like
230 thousand years ago and then humans
came in to Europe earlier like maybe
40,000 or 45,000 years ago they had to
make sure that humans had something to
do with the disappearance of
Neanderthals okay and here you can see
it from the papers themselves here's
Finlayson 1999 a middle Palaeolithic
industry was recovered associated with
the earth tell you how they figure this
out from which charcoal was dated to
circa 32 to 33 thousand years ago
artifacts from these levels are of
mysterion condition mysterion is that
technology so this guy's saying okay we
found any and earth all and we dated him
to 32 to 33 thousand years ago right
couple months later a few months later
two thousand year we have of chinoco
and he says oh no the last and earth all
died in my turf radiocarbon dating
estimated the specimen to be twenty nine
thousand years ago and therefore from
one of the last the latest living and
results okay so now he beat the other
guy by three thousand years okay so now
what happens
riches comes two thousand the tune and
earth all specimens were dated to twenty
nine thousand years before the president
twenty eight thousand years before the
present making them the youngest
directly dated Nana those specimens in
Europe so how you beat him by a thousand
yes right and then Finland son comes
back two thousand six here we present
data based on a high-resolution record
of human occupation of gorons cave
Gibraltar that established the survival
of a population of Andrew those two
twenty eight thousand years before the
present these handles are the left
currently recorded anywhere it's always
the punchline yeah it's it's a
competition for who got the last name at
all and they get their names in lights
and they get to do all these things yeah
now went through a bucket of cold ice
cold water on the Neanderthal
competition on the last NFL competition
was a study made by Tom Ryan
he's from he's from the carbon-14 group
lab that dates all kinds of findings
right they talk kinds of samples and
specimens in Oxford and he's considered
an authority at least as far as
carbon-14 dating and at least you can
say well he's trying to be as consistent
as possible across the board so if he
dates this thirty thousand years more
than likely when he dates something else
it's gonna be in reference to that
whether you accept the absolute values
or not they're at least reference to
each other okay and he says we show that
the musterion
technology that the Neanderthals
we show that the mysterion ended by 41
to 39,000 calibrated years before the
present across Europe the last Nanda
Falls did not survive after 41,000 to
39,000 calibrated years before the
present so that means a Neanderthal
according to Tom hi I'm in his room died
around rounding off 40,000 years ago
so this grew a bucket of cold ice all
these other claims that the Neanderthal
survived to thirty thousand twenty-nine
twenty-eight thousand years ago now I'm
not saying he does all I'm saying is
that he's trusted first of all across
the board second he's got his reading
reference to his other reading so
they're all he's consistent within
himself okay okay and this was a bucket
of cold ice because all these people
were claiming that animals survived 230
thousand years ago this guy say no they
died ten thousand years earlier
now this created a problem for all the
people who had theories based on the
fact that humans had something to do
with the extinction of the Neanderthals
because if humans did not appear let's
assume that none if humans did not
appear in Europe until let's say thirty
five thousand years ago and here the
Neanderthals died five thousand years
earlier we had nothing to do with the
extinction this we did a problem that's
all I'm saying by appear in Europe you
mean that they came supposedly the
general theory is that humans migrated
out of africa and they went north to
Europe but they entered Europe around
35,000 years ago or would I make that
assumption let's assume that humans did
come into Europe no earlier than 35,000
years ago
if the Neanderthals died 40,000 years
ago they never met and humans had
nothing to do with the extinction of an
animal here you have the cages it's
train costs 2003 directly accelerator
mass spectrometry radiocarbon c14
dated to 34,000 to 36,000
years before the present the ouais one
mandible is the oldest definite early
modern human specimen in Europe so could
either this read if we're gonna look at
objective data if there is anything like
we've even imagined that the closest
thing to it encloses into it the first
human enters that we found so far right
that we found so far enters here at
35,000 years ago and the last mammoth
all died 40,000 years ago according to
this group's readings and they're
trusted and a lot of them are accepted
widely by the paleontology you know Gil
the people in paleontology so what
happened next well they went from the
since they they had a problem there they
said well hold it if the first human
entered 5,000 years after the
Neanderthals died but you know maybe
humans had nothing to do with an end I
thought we can't believe that because 92
99 percent of our theories of our
beliefs are that humans did cause the
exchange of the Neanderthals one way or
another why do they clean so much on the
humans because they can't figure out any
other reason how the Neanderthals could
have died all by themselves and so so
what happened was a new competition
developed and this is this is read 80 or
reclassifying human specimens I mean the
end of of specimens and their re
classifying them as humans yeah they
have Neanderthal bones and they're
calling humans more or less that's
essentially what they're doing they have
they don't have a whole head because
that would be too obvious
but if they have a one tooth and they
said well this to really did not belong
to the ANA though it was really human
and it's dated to 45,000 years ago now
we can see how they you know they
and they mingled and they did all their
stuff so now they're reading or either
reading or reclassifying so this one is
40,000 years ago
and instead of calling it in the end
without blowing 40,000 years ago they're
calling it a human it's a 40,000 year
old human bone you got it
that's what they're doing and here we
have a case it's also from hinds group
he says Casey floor that's Kent cavern
for number four dates to 44,000 to
41,000 years before the present where is
Kevin oh that's in England right this
makes it older than any other equipment
let me dated modern human specimen okay
that's what he says in his report but he
adds something which shows you how to
play around with us we also show that in
13 dental traits
casey for Kent cabin four possesses
modern human rather than nano though
characteristics three other traits shown
and earth all affinities and a further
seven are unbeaten so they don't know
what they have but they want to consider
it in a human because that way they can
show that ah see humans were in England
you know what is it 44,000 years before
the present so they had 4000 years until
the Nano so disappeared to mingle and
meet and mingle and here's another
example of the same thing and not see
2011 here we really analyzed that the
serious molars right from the growth of
the Koala originally classified as nano
though we show that the Cavallo
specimens can be attributed to
anatomically modern humans the teeth
must date to 45,000 to 43,000 calendar
years before the present so now they're
taking all these Neanderthal bones
calling them humans and they see you
know these people were humans were in
Europe 45,000 years before the present
and without side forty thousand years
because everybody's now accepting more
or less Tom Hynes group
Fighting's and they say see 5000 years
where we mix them mingled the issue is
that all the theories that are based on
humans having something to do with the
extinction of the nano-cells
are based on you know the two species
having met you know and encounter that
so very at least being in the same time
period right and all I'm saying there's
no objective evidence right now that
they were at the same place at the same
time anywhere you know we don't have a
protective evidence for this that's the
first one so any theory based on humans
having something to do with the
extinction of the Neanderthals is you
cannot take for granted the assumption
that we even met that's the first one
and the second one is that yeah there's
a lot of playing around the dates and
the samples because people have they'd
already made up their minds of what they
want to prove and now they're just
modifying the data they're playing
around with the data to make it fit
their preconceived you know conclusion
[Music]
cool girl so what do you think we should
do with the admixture theus well let me
tell you what I think come on now
[Music]